a group of migrants crossed the tuesa
river into Bako chikito the latest
victims of a growing number of Bandits
now operating in the daden
jungle they describe the men who robbed
them to Panama's Border
Police two were armed with rifles and
three had machetes and one was on
Horseback one after another the migrants
tell us the same
story they stole everything even the
food for the child
the migrants arrive in Bahu chikito with
no food or money to continue their
Journey some of the women have been
sexually molested or even
raped 11-year-old Enrique puera and his
sister SAR are among the many children
we find who seemed desperate to tell us
about their ordeal with their parents'
permission there were many Bandits
around they wore masks and came out with
guns and when we were on the road we
heard a lot of shots and we saw dead
people I got very scared when the
bandage shot a man's foot that made me
very scared I was also scared when I saw
a woman who was dead in a river
alongside a child they were already
eaten all that was left was their
legs thousands of children are
experiencing the same
thing but they're also stories of
sacrifice and selfishness
I went across the river and I almost
drowned because of exhaustion the water
was very deep I survived thanks to this
Cuban man my nephew and another man who
saved
me this Haitian woman was dying from
dehydration but was saved by two
strangers she's a human being we can't
just abandon her I told her that I would
come back for her I reached the village
and I brought her down on this stretcher
Panamanian Border Police concede they
need more resources to contain the
escalating crime wave in the jungle and
keep migrants from
danger danger that's not deterring those
risking their lives to escape poverty
and violence at home Lucia Newman Al
jazer dang Gap
Panama make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer